en casi tres décadas más de 30 países
han tomado medidas para legalizar o
ampliar el acceso al aborto
la mayoría de los votos un millón 429
mil 981 están a favor de la propuesta
después de irlanda en 2018 argentina
otro país tradicionalmente católico se
convirtió en la primera gran nación
latinoamericana en legalizar el
procedimiento en 2020 méxico no pudo
escapar la llamada ola verde su corte
suprema- voto a favor de la
despenalización del aborto el año pasado
aunque la situación varía según el
estado en febrero de este año colombia
siguió sus pasos el máximo tribunal de
ese país dictaminó que abortar antes de
la semana 24 de embarazo ya no es un
delito
y la pretensión de nuestra demanda era
otra nosotras queríamos que la corte
declarara inconstitucional el delito
aborto es un servicio de salud que debe
estar regulado por iniciativa iniciativa
sanitaria es decir en el ámbito de la
salud no en un código penal mientras
varios países de américa latina han
aflojado las cuerdas en cuanto al acceso
al aborto otras naciones como honduras
nicaragua y el salvador mantienen la
prohibición total este último país
incluso ha pasado a introducir más
restricciones prohibiendo la
interrupción del embarazo en cualquier
circunstancia las mujeres siguen
protestando pidiendo que se cambien las
leyes pero sin éxito
que está negativa gubernamental que
ahora mismo estamos encontrando
consideramos que son cortinas de humo
para retroceder en otro derecho
en europa polonia ha endurecido las
restricciones en los últimos años en
áfrica a varios países mantienen la
prohibición total otros permiten el
aborto para salvar la vida de las
mujeres o preservar su salud física o
mental benin fue a contracorriente en
octubre de 2021 legalizando el aborto
hasta las 12 semanas de gestación
uniéndose así a sudáfrica mozambique
cabo verde y túnez